When I'm mentoring young entrepreneurs,
I ask them about money and
their business model.
When I get an answer like,
we'll throw some ads here and
there, it makes me real sad.
It's the wrong answer.
You must have a solid business
model in place that will put
your company on the profitable track.
>> So, even if ads are the answer
to your monetization model,
you need to put a little
bit more thought into it.
So, let's define what an ad is first.
Basically, it's any public announcement
of something that someone wants to sell.
On the web we have ads in the form of
text, image, video or interactive media.
The power of these ads is coming
from the fact that they are targeted
to site content and our audience.
You make ad spaces, also known as ad
inventory, available on your site.
Advertisers bid to show their ads on
your site and the highest bid wins.
Then you get paid when
users click on the ads.
>> This model works when
you have lucrative traffic,
meaning you focus on verticals that
advertisers are interested in.
For example, a finance or an automotive
site with a lot of users will earn
higher CPMs than a site that
focus on fish or white elephants.